and Jeremy dad of three and it's like
for me are you like a really
embarrassing father only when I speak
all being the same yeah I mean can you
imagine how awful it would be to wake up
now I was your father because you're
your eldest girl is she 18 now 1990 so
there must be gentlemen callers
this is gentleman caller is a current
very strong gentleman caller who is he's
from Dublin so is it's this is how I
spend the day with him so it's like yes
they love him and she's loved up so
she's very happy and are you very happy
or that weird no eat well cause it's
weird because you know she was in the
pram eight minutes ago and now she's
boyfriend but he's but the thing is is
I'm supposed to hate him I mean I always
said he'd bring even big anyone who
liked him long as they don't have a
motorcycle is it that one motorcyclist
was simply set fire to and if he goes
and buys another one I'll simply set
fire to that what they do but they're
not going on motorcycles that was just
the the bare-bones really he doesn't
ever most he doesn't drive he hasn't got
a clue who I am he the Bandit is
tremendous you know I'm very happy
they're they're really sweet couple so
it's been don't you find it works that
if if that person makes them happy
then you're happy exactly and she is
plainly very happy Wendy's around saying
you know that's tremendous news and the
others are just normal kids which is
cool
now I'm do I'll come gestured or my
children as everybody in the world does
right answer yeah if you gone first yeah
they're alright yeah you were relatively
old to be on my mom weren't you I was 43
when I had my first child yes and what
are some what not embarrassing incidents
with moments well you're quite a few
times I wasn't actually taken to be
their mother but a slightly older
relative
we took my daughter Eliza when she was
about six she hurt Ryan we took her to
A&E with a friend of mine came through
on holiday and the this junior doctor
came in and young sort of Australian guy
and started explaining everything to my
friend and then he turned to me and he
went a Watters name thing surprisingly
nan thought he was a [ __ ]
yah-hoo basis a lot of her act or merely
her costume in the world with a better
than America Burma and the Ukraine
billion times better than the night